we're told expressed the point on the
number line as both a fraction and a
decimal so pause this video and have a
go at that all right now let's do this
together so we can see that the point in
question it's at a higher value than
four and it's less than five so greater
than four less than five and the space
between four and five is divided into
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten equal sections
so each of these hash marks represent an
extra tenth so this is four then this is
4 and 1/10 and now this is 4 right over
here and two tenths so we could write
this if we wanted to write it as a
fraction or as a mixed number this would
be four and two tenths and if we wanted
to write that as a decimal that would be
four and then in the tenths place well
we have two tenths and that's it we're
done let's do another example so here
we're once again asked to express the
point on the number line is both a
fraction and a decimal but this one's a
little bit different but see how you if
you can identify how it is different and
and answer the question so pause this
video and once again have a go at it
alright so here our point it's not
between two whole numbers it's actually
between two tenths where between 3 & 2
tenths and three and three tenths so
this is between 3 & 2 tenths and three
and three tenths so each of these hash
marks which are a tenth of a tenth so
they would actually be a hundredth so
one way to think about it
you could view 3.2 or 3 and 2 tenths as
3 and 20 hundredths and you could view 3
& 3 tenths as 3 and 30 hundredths and so
this is 3 and 20 hundredths this is 23
and 21 hundredths three and twenty two
hundredths so this point right over here
is 3 and 22 hundreds 22 hundreds and of
course you could also write that as a
mixed number that is 3 and 22
over 100 now another way that you could
have approached it is hey I'm starting
at three point two or three and two
tenths and I'm so I'm starting here at
three point two and then I'm going to
add to that not just one hundredths but
two hundredths so it would be three two
tenths and then two hundredths and there
you have it we've expressed it as both a
fraction and a decimal